c'est nommé monsieur le procureur
général de la république des proches
française dans son implacable
réquisitoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
françaises français belges belge
monsieur le président mon cher maître
monsieur le crieur d'aline pour qu'elle
revienne
mesdames et messieurs les jurés public
chéri mon amour la cour dans son infinie
mansuétude aura-t-elle la bonté de me
pardonner une fois de plus ma coupable
incompétence qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
encore à la suite d'une confusion
mentale dus aux excès d'une vie nocturne
extraordinairement riche en péripéties
amoureuses digne de la rome antique et
de la bauge à cochons je me suis éveillé
la tête vide incapable de me rappeler
l'identité de l'homme que nous devions
condamné à mort aujourd'hui c'est bien
ce que je pensais ge était d'une humeur
de chihuahua c'est le président oui je
sais habituellement andy l'humeur de
chiens moi je précise la marque
chihuahua et c'est pas par hasard ça
fait la deuxième fois en deux mois que
je glisse sur un chihuahua c'est
d'ailleurs le vrai problème pour les
gens comme nous qui sommes obligés de
travailler dans le xvième pour gagner
notre vie à chaque instant nous risquons
de nous prendre les pieds dans un
chihuahua qu'est ce qu'un chihuahua le
mot chihuahua vient de la langue hispano
un cas qu'on peut encore entendre parler
de nos jours dans les faubourgs
populaires de mexico où les descendants
des fils du soleil mange la bonne soupe
aux grizzlies slovaques dans leur igloo
sicilien vous m'arrêtez ce que je dis
des conneries que veut dire si huawei
est bien dans chihuahua il y as she et
il y à wawa de même que dans pampelune
il y en a une et qu'elle dont jean paul
ii il ya 2
[Applaudissements]
alors que signifie d'une part et wawa
d'autre part et bien tout simplement
chihuahua veut dire littéralement
crottes de chiens c'est tout bête à ce
stade de cette magistrale leçon de
sciences naturelles
c'est plutôt une leçon de choses et je
voudrais m'arrêter pour m'adresser plus
particulièrement aux personnes sensibles
distinguer et de bon goût qui pourrait
écouter cette émission par hasard dans
l'erreur
je viens de dire crottes je sais c'est
très très dur à l'audition de ce mot des
milliers d'entre vous ont sursauté et
baisser le son de la radio pour que les
enfants n'entendent pas ce mot orduriers
que la morale réprouve
eh bien vous avez bien fait car si tous
les enfants du monde répétait le mot
crottes
on serait pas dans la merde il ne faut
d'ailleurs pas croire que les enfants se
délecte de mots cruels entre eux quand
les parents ne sont pas là pour les
surveiller que font les petits enfants
de france
ils parlent de dieu de la nature du
théorème de pythagore ou encore de la
possibilité de confier le ministère de
l'écologie à michel crépeau dans un
éventuel gouvernement mitterrand voilà
de quoi parlent les chers petits les
gros mots ils n'en connaissent ils ne
connaîtraient aucun s'il n'y avait pas
la radio il n'aime pas les gros mots les
enfants ma fille de 6 ans me disait il
ya quelques jours
papa je ne veux plus jouer avec sophie
pourquoi lui dis je les aime bien je
croyais que c'était ta meilleure amie
oui papa mais elle n'arrête pas de me
faire chier avec ses gros mot
dante les enfants n'aiment pas les gros
mots et puisque nous en sommes à évoquer
le rôle de la radio et son influence
parmi les jeunes
je voudrais également fustigé ici
publiquement certaines émissions ou non
content de dire des gros mots comme n 2
dé ou p2b jeudi p2b f1 de ne pas faire
publicité oh [ __ ] de bordel bien sûr
certaines émissions ou certains
irresponsables pousse le mauvais goût
jusqu'à se moquer des infirmes ou des
nains ou même des nains cul-de-jatte et
ça vous voulez que je vous dise c'est
vraiment petit c'est indigne car un un
cul-de-jatte est un homme comme tout le
monde il a droit au respect de ses
frères humains
le nain cul-de-jatte a le droit de
redresser la tête quand même intérêt en
traversant la rue sinon je vais vous le
demande
que voulez vous qu'il en dresse d'autres
apprenons à vivre ensemble comme le dit
si bien mon beau frère
avec ce cheminot d'un cul de jatte
lui-même depuis qu'il a perdu trois de
ses plus beaux membres sous le paris
vintimille cet homme je parle toujours
mon beau-frère cet homme réussit
cependant à vivre dignement pour ajouter
du beurre dans son plancton ils mangent
pas l'épinard sa loge pas il ne se
contente pas de son humble pension de
rétracter de la sncf le soir le soir il
fait cariatides sur la face nord du café
des deux n'a beau à paris et le samedi
matin il fait buste de marianne presse
papier sur le bureau des mariages de la
mairie
de la mairie de gorge les petites
connaissent dans leur ensemble il est
vilain dans le 35 ille et vilaine oui le
nain cul-de-jatte a droit à notre estime
et à notre respect laissons-la dormir
dans son carton à chapeau cessons de lui
filer des coups de pied dans l'oeuf en
dansant le tango et d'essuyer les
crottes des chihuahuas de nos semelles
sur ses cheveux judicieusement taillé en
brosse à cet effet ce sont également de
nous servir de la radiodiffusion pour
nous gausser de la religion et de
l'armée que la sainte vierge et vous
n'êtes pas de poil aux pattes qu'est ce
que ça change
personnellement je pense qu'il en avait
sinon elle aurait pas commander c'est sa
robe de bure pack 1 mondial lee qu est
le plus gros salaire de ligue 1 et puis
d'ailleurs vous trouvez que c'est drôle
vous d'avoir du poil aux pattes
déjà que ça doit pas être marrant d'être
vierge quant à l'armée songez-vous que
s'il n'y avait pas d'armes et il n'y
aurait pas de guerre et s'il n'y avait
pas de guerre qu'est ce qu'on mettrait
sur les monuments aux morts
le plan du patelin à côté et la faute au
tir ac de l'autre non j'aime encore
mieux
j'aime encore mieux de bonne guerre ou
alors les monuments aux morts ont pour
elle est transformée en monument aux
vivants ce serait peut-être pas idiot
trifouilly les oies à ses enfants pas
morts pour la france 1939 45
albert audibert charcutier gilbert
dupont boulanger louis durand boucher
samuel goldschmidt entire rachel
golstein sa femme monique golstein sa
fille pierre golstein son fils n'en est
pas là pour faire de l'anti nazisme
primaire en résumé nous pouvons dire que
les chihuahuas l'ena les culs de jatte
la sainte vierge et le général bigeard
sont des victimes donc christophe est
coupable ça me paraît clair
de plus monsieur christophe on me dit
que vous chantez est ce bien raisonnable
comment se fait-il que tant d tant de
gens s'obstinent encore à chanter quand
on pense à tout ce qu'on peut faire
d'autre avec la bouche comme route et la
barbe à papa par exemple pourquoi chars
christophe avez vous choisi la chanson
qui devait vous conduire sur la pente
fatale du vice et du vice la guillotine
alors que vous aviez entre les mains ce
merveilleux métier de trieurs de
lentilles dans une conserverie de lille
si j'ai bien lu le dossier quoi oui sa
petite amie l'avait plaquée parce qu'il
était pauvre
alors pour s'enrichir rapidement
christophe pendant des jours et des
nuits à séparer les cailloux des
lentilles dans un faubourg lillois dans
l'espoir que sa fiancée lui revienne un
jour comme il l'a dit lui-même à
l'instruction et j'ai trié trier à lille
pour qu'elle revienne je traînais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est non non